كانت قوات الدعم السريع استجابتها لما
وصفتها بنداءات دوليه واقليميه لتمديد
العمل بالهدنه الانسانيه اثنتين وسبعين
ساعه اعتبارا من منتصف الليله الفاصله بين
الاحد والاثنين كانت تلك القوات قد تبادلت
مع الجيش الاتهامات بحرق الهدنه الخامسه
ما يطرح السؤال عن مصير الجهود الدوليه
الراميه لوقت القتال وكلفته الانسانيه
المتفاقمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
اسباب هشاشه الهدى بين الجيش السوداني
وقوه الدعم السريع في ضوء اعلان كل طرف
التزامه بالهدنه بينما يستمر القتال على
الارض
وكيف ينعكس هذا المشهد على الوضع الانساني
وجهود اغاثه المدنيين معترد المستويات
المعيشيه والصحيه والامنيه في البلاد
وما هي فرص نجاح المبادرات الامميه
والافريقيه والامريكيه لوقف القتال في ضوء
الحديث عن رغبه لدى الطرفين بحوار مباشر
بينهما خارج السودان
[موسيقى]
من هدنه الى اخرى يمضي المشهد السوداني
نحو فصول جديده من الصراع المسلح بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع دون ان تنجح تلك
الهدى في الهدف الاساسي الذي من اجله وجدت
وهو وقف القتال وحقن الدماء وزاره الصحه
السودانيه اكدت ان الاشتباكات التي استمرت
متقطعه رغم الهدن اوقعت قرابه 550 قتيلا
واربعه الاف وستمئه جريح في احصائيه مؤقته
في حين تشير توقعات الى ارقام اعلى من ذلك
الامم المتحده قالت ان المعارك اجبرت اكثر
من 30 الف شخص على النزوح داخل البلاد
وحذرت الامم المتحده من ان عدد الفارين من
القتال قد يصلوا الى اكثر من 270 الفا اذا
تواصلت المعارك
وزير خارجيه جيبوتي ارجع اخفاق الهدن الى
غياب التواصل بين طرفي النزاع
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الخرطوم الهندي عز الدين الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن الخرطوم ايضا عبر الهاتف حافظ
كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كما ينضم
الينا من ابو جادفيد
مدير مركز جنيد للامن والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا وابدا معك سيد
الهندي بالحديث عن الهدنه الاخيره التي
اعلنت الدعم السريع انه ملتزم بها او
بالاحرى تمديد الهدنه اثنتين وسبعين ساعه
اضافيه في حين لم نسمع من القوات المسلحه
موقف بشان هوائيه التي كانت في السابق
السباقه في قبول الهدى لكن هذه المره لا
موقف لماذا
مرحبا بك وبمشاهدين الجزيره اينما كانوا
طبعا هذه الهدن اصبحت هدى اعلاميه
ودبلوماسيه بصوره اساسيه اكثر منها هدى
حربيه
الطرفان يريدان ان يكسبها المجتمع الدولي
بالذات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
باعتبار انها هي التي طلبت ابتداء هذه
الهدن ولكن على ارض الواقع ارض المعركه
كلما حانت فرصه لطرف لانقض على طرف اخر
ليهاجم معسكر او يهاجم رتل من السيارات
يحدث ذلك وبالتالي
عمليا ليس هنالك التزام بهذه الهدن ولا
اتوقع التزام بها ما لم يحقق كل طرف
الغايه الاساسيه التي من اجلها قامت هذه
الحرب الدعم السريع
لماذا
يعلن عن الهدن
كما قلت لك هي رساله محاوله لتبويض الوجه
لتبييض الوجه امام المجتمع التوليد دعم
السريع يريد ان يقول انه قوه ملتزمه
منضبطه متعاونه مع المجتمع الدولي الدعم
السريع لديه مشاكل مع المجتمع الدولي
سابقا فيما يتعلق بحرب دارفور في 2003
وبالتالي يريد ان يكسب المجتمع الدولي
بذات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اصلا
الدعم السريع كل هذه المشكله والازمه
وتبني الدعم السريع للاتفاق الايطالي كان
الاساسي منه يرضى المجتمع
ومحاوله تبييض الوجه مع الدوليا طيب هذا
الهدف الذي الذي تنسيبه للدعم السريع الا
ينسحب ايضا على القوات المسلحه
طبعا ايضا قوات المسلحه تسعى الى هذا
الهدف العلاقه مع المجتمع الدولي معلوم ان
قائد الجيش لديه علاقات جيده الفريق عبد
الفتاح البرهان مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه علاقته افضل مع امريكا علاقه مع
اسرائيل والرئيس السوداني الوحيد الذي
التقى علنا برئيس وزراء اسرائيل
نتنياهو في فبراير 2020 في كمبالا
وبالتالي الطرفين يزعيان للتقرب الى مجتمع
الدوله لكن حقيقه اعتقد ان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه الى تحقيق وضع افضل كسر جبهه
التمرد بالذات في وسط القرب ومن بعد ذلك
ستكون هذه الهدن الحقيقيه
صيد حافظ كبير لو سالنا قوات الدعم السريع
او الجيش من المسؤول عن خرق هذه الهدى كل
طرف
بالمسؤوليه على الطرف الاخر لكن النتيجه
واحده ان هذه الهدن لا تصمد رغم الاعلان
عنها بشكل متكرر لماذا
يستمر الاعلان عن هذه الهدن وكل مره طرف
يعلن عنها يعني المره الماضيه الجيش هو
الذي اعلن عن الهدنه وتاخر الدعم السريع
في الموافقه واليوم العكس هو الذي يحصل
الدعم السريع يعلن عن الهدنه ولم يصدر
موقف من الجيش حتى اللحظه يعني ما هذه
الاستراتيجيه التي يتبعها الطرفان في
موضوع الهدن
تحيه طيبه لك ولضيوفك الكرام ولمشاهديكم
الكرام اعتقد ان
الاستراتيجيه واضحه هنا ان الدعم السريع
من ناحيته يقول بانه يستجيب للمناهلات
الدوليه وانه يستجيب ذلك للاغراض
الانسانيه التي يعني هي تعيش الان الاوضاع
الانسانيه تعيش حاله معقده وبالتالي هناك
ايضا اتهام له لانه ينتشر يعني اذا فحصنا
هذه التصريحات نجد بان الدعم السريع هو
منتشر في الخرطوم بعكس القوات المسلحه
التي لديها اماكن موجوده بها وبالتالي هذا
الانتشار تستغله القوات المسلحه باعتباره
خلقا للهدنه وتقوموا
تحريك طائراتها وبالتالي تسقط القنابل على
على تحركات الدعم السريعه الدعم السريع
كما هي تقول وتصرح لا ليس لديه مقار الان
موجود بها لكن في اماكن معينه لديه مقر
يوجد بها في الصالحه وفي عدد من الاماكن
يعني نحن نتحدث عفوا سيد حافظ يعني هذا ما
كنت اود ان اتجاوزه في السؤال بغض النظر
عمن يتهم الاخر الدعم السريع هو الذي يخرق
الجيش هو الذي يخرق الهدن في النهايه نحن
امام حقيقه واحده ان هذه الهدن لا تصمد
رغم ان الطرفين يتسابقان على اعلانها
سؤالي لماذا السيد الهندي اجاب بان
الموضوع تبييض وجه لدى الولايات المتحده
والمجتمع الدولي اسالك هل الامر كذلك وهل
هذه الهدى فقط من اجل تسيير او تمرير
عمليات الاج لاء الدوليه
انا بالطبع اتفق مع الاستاذ الهندي في
الجزء في جزء من من تحليله لهذه لهذه
الاستراتيجيه باعتبار ان الطرفان الطرفين
ينظران الى المجتمع الدولي بعين الاعتبار
لكن هناك ايضا مصلحه اخرى للدعم السريع في
الهدنه المستفيد منها هو لديه قوات منتشره
في الخرطوم ليست لديها مقار وبالتالي
الهدنه هي تحقق له مكاتب كذلك الهدنه كما
يقول اتحقق مكاتب اخرى منها مكاتب انسانيه
لكن يعني اذا
هذا الجانب
الى الهدنه نجد ان الدعم السريع مستفيد من
الهدنه باعتباره يعني يحتاج الى لم اوضاعه
ويحتاج
الى بعكس الجيش لكن بصوره عامه الجيش مصر
على تحقيق نصر ما يريد ان يحقق يعني ازاحه
الدعم السريع من الاماكن التي يوجد فيها
خاصه الاماكن الاستراتيجيه وبعد ذلك يمكن
ان يكون
الالتزام منطقيا بالنسبه لجنوده الذين
يعني يجدون الان حرجا كبيرا في الاجابه عن
سؤال لماذا ينتشر الدعم السريع في الشوارع
وتغيب القوات المسلحه سيد ديفيد
الاليه ثلاثيه في السودان
يبدو انها تعول على تلك الهدى ولو انها
هدى تخرق من من وقت الى اخر اخر موقف
للاليه الثلاثيه في السودان
تقول بان تلك الهدن انما تمهد لمفاوضات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع لوقف دائم لاطلاق
النار وهي تدعو لتمديد الهدنه الحاليه هل
هذا الهدف واقعي هل ترى فعلا ان الهدن
المتتاليه يمكن ان توصل في النهايه الى
وقف دائم لاطلاق النار علما انها هدى
منهشه كما هو واضح
الافضليه في وقت لاطلاق النار او للهدنه
هو ان هناك دليل
من الطرفين لاسامه قياده كل من الطرفين
لتواصل الى اتفاق ما من خلال
وسطتان اقليميه او دوليه في ذلك افضليه
راينا ان هذه الهدنه تكون هشه بما ان
الاشتباكات والمواجهه تستمر والامر بسيط
فطرفان لا يزالان يتنازعان من اجل تعزيز
موقفهما لاسيما للسيطره على بنى تحتيه
دعونا لا ننسى القوات المسلحه السودانيه
في موقف دفاعي تقريبا بين مقوات الدعم
السريع تحاول السيطره على بعض من هذه
المواقع المشكله في الهدنه او في وقف
لاطلاق النار هو انه من جهه كما تحدث احد
الضيفين هو انها لا
او
تسمحان او هذه الهدن عفوا تسمح للاسره
الدوليه برؤيه الطرفين على انه ما يتمتعني
بانضباط
ولكننا لم نرى اي فعاليه لهذه الهدن لان
المواجهه السامير انا لا طالما قلت ان
افضل حل هو الجمع بين الجن رلين والمصالحه
بينهما لان المشكله الاساسيه هنا تكمن في
ان الطرفين يتنازعان على
السيطره على البلاد اذا الهدنه هي مؤشر
لاحتمال توصل الى اتفاق ولكن من جهه اخرى
هي تظهر ان هناك
تفاوت بين قرارات القياده
والتنفيذ على الارض حيث ليس هناك احترام
لقرارات القياده
يعني يعني افهم يعني هذه النقطه عدم
احترام قرارات القياده ايضا كل طرف يلقي
بالمسؤوليه فيها على الطرف الاخر بنفس
اللغه وبنفس العبارات افهم منك بانك توافق
وزير الخارجيه الجيبوتي عندما قال ان
اخفاق هذه الهدن سببه عدم التواصل المباشر
بين الطرفين
الى فشل الهدن فهو غياب الثقه بين الطرفين
فهذا يتجلى
غياب ثقه ولكن من جهه اخرى من وجهه نظر
عسكريه لا يمكنك التوصل الى هدنه اذا لم
تتحكم بالمنى تحتيها الاساسيه ما يسعى
اليه كل طرفه هو السيطره مثلا من يسيطر
على القصر الرئاسي من يسيطر على المقر
العسكريه هذا يعطيك افضليه حين تاتي الى
طاوله المفاوضات هذه المكاسب العسكريه
الميدانيه اذا كل منهما يحاول تعزيز موقفه
وموقعه وقبل ذلك سوف لن يحصل اي اتفاق
دائم
لوقف اطلاق النار عود
عز الدين النقطه التي اثارها سيد ديفيد من
ابوجا هي نقطه هامه موضوع تعدد مراكز
القرار لدى كل من
الجيش او الدعم السريع الدعم السريع يتهم
الجيش بان بانه ليس هناك قرار مركزي داخل
القياده وهذا يؤدي الى تاخر في اعلان
الهدن او الموافقه عليها او حتى الالتزام
بها والعكس صحيح هو نفس الامر يحاول الجيش
ان يسحبه بالاتهام على الدعم السريع الى
اي مدى تعتقد فعلا ان هناك
تعدد وتنازع مراكز قوى داخل الطرفين يعني
توصل الى نتيجه وهي هشاشه وخرق الهدن
المتتاليه
لا اعتقد ان في القوات المسلحه بصوره
اساسيه ان هناك تعدد مراكز قرار هنالك
قياده مرتبه منظمه الجيش السوداني مؤسسه
عسكريه راسخه عمرها 100 عام وبالتالي
موضوع التفلت وتعدد مراكز القرار في
القوات المسلحه غير وارد تماما الا اذا
حدث انقلاب حينما يحدث انقلاب فان القائد
الجديد هو الذي يقود المنظومه العسكريه
كيفما تكون هذه يعني دعايه سوداء اطلقها
اعلام الدعم السريع والمستشار السياسي
للدعم السريع يقول ان هنالك اسلاميين في
الجيش وهنالك فلول وهم الذين يسيطرون هذه
قديمه مكرره واصبحت
مموجه يعني الحديث عن ان الجيش باسلاميين
هم الذين يقودون ان البرهان مجرد الصوره
هذا حديث هم يعلمون انه غير صحيح لان
البرهان انتم الى القوات المسلحه وكذلك
العطاء قبل الانقاذ نفسها وبالتالي لم
يدخله الى الجيش لم يدخله الحركه
الاسلاميه تاريخه القديم ولا يعرف احد في
الجيش للبرهان اي تاريخ علاقه للبرهان
بالحركه الاسلاميه ولكن ولا ياسر العطاء
بالعكس العطف فانه كان اقرب لقوى الحريه
ولكن هذه كل هذه الفديه يريد بها تشتيت
الكره امام الملعب الاساسي يريدون التضليل
يريدون التغليش الراي العام
بالنسبه للدعم السريع هو هنالك
مؤسسي لانها بصوره اساسيه مليشه غير
منضبطه يعني مثلا هناك اعمال نهر وسلب
واعتداء على بيوت المواطنين كما حدث لمنزل
السيد مبارك الفاضل المهدي بصور موجود في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وفي القنوات بسته
كما حدثوا الاعتداء على منزل السيد محمد
عثمان المرغد الزعيم الحزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي الاصلي ومرشد الختميه هذا يدل
على تقليدات في القاعه في القاعده بالنسبه
للدعم السريع هذا لا يحدث في الجيش
في هذه النقطه سيد حافظ
يعني هناك يعني عوامل كثيره جدا تجعلنا
نشك في كل الاقوال التي تاتي والتي يقولها
الاستاذ الهندي قبل قليل قالها قبل قليل
يعني نحن نرى ان هناك تعدد في مراكز
القرار داخل الجيش هذا مفهوم وصرح به اكثر
من مره قادم في الجيش لانه بان الجيش يريد
ذلك وانه لن يسمح نقادته بالمضيف للات
فاق هناك ايضا معلومات موثقه ومعلومه في
ان المؤتمر الوطني كيف ادخل يعني عناصر
عناصر منه في الجيش طوال الثلاثين عاما
الماضي هذا معلوم حتى ادان نقاش حول كيفيه
اخراجهم او كيفيه ابعاد المؤسسه العسكريه
من تاثيرات النظام الباقي وكذلك
قال نفسه يعني
المؤتمر الوطني من التلاعب او من التدخل
في الجيش كذلك البرهان نفسه كان يوم من
الايام هو رئيس المؤتمر الوطني في محليه
وكان لا يمكن ان نتصور الا
يكون في محليه عندما معتمدا في محليه لكن
سيد حافظ انت ايضا
نعم سيد حافظ انت ايضا انت ايضا استمعت
الى سيد الهندي عندما قال بان قوات الدعم
السريع تركيبتها تركيبا ميليشياويه
وبالتالي هذه التركيبه
تجعلها غير منظمه
وتقوم باعمال نهب وسلب وامور خارجه عن
القانون وهو ما لا يمكن ان تقوم به القوات
المسلحه بمعنى الجيش ما رايك في ذلك
هذه الحرب قذره تستخدم في تستخدم فيها
ادوات مختلفه الطرفان لديهم زي الطرف
الاخر وهناك ايضا مستعمل يعني نحن لا
نستطيع التاكد من ان الذي يقوم بهذا الفعل
ينتمي الى هذه الجهه الامنيه نحن تابعنا
سواء كان الجيش اول دعم السريع اتهامات
تطالهم سواء كان ذلك في دارفور او في
اماكن مختلفه يعني هذا ليس غريبا طالما
المناخ الذي نعيشه مناخ حرب تستخدم في
ادوات مختلفه لكن بصوره عامه
اذا مثل ما يقول الهندي وان الجيش مؤ
منظمه الى يعني كيف يفسر مثلا الخروقات
الكبيره والواسعه والطيران الذي يقصف
المقار وكذلك يعني هذا معلوم بانه كان
ينبغي ان تكون الخرقان اقل او انها تكون
في الشكل الاشتباكات الطيران يقسم اماكن
لا وجود للجيش فيها ولا وجود الاشتباكات
ارضيه كما نتابع نحن في اماكن ايضا ليس
فيها وجود للدعم
السريع نعود اعود الى ضيفنا نعم السيد
ديفيد حتى حتى نعطيه ايضا وقتا بهذا
النقاش حول الطرفين
يعني امام هذه الاتهامات التي باتت مكرره
وامام هشاشه الوضع العسكري
الثابت الوحيد حتى الان عمليات الاجلاء
تسير من دون عوائق هل هذا ما هو مطلوب
دوليا في المرحله الرائنه قبل الحديث عن
اي تفاوض عن اي وقت لاطلاق النار عن اي
تواصل بين البرهان وحميدتي المطلوب النجاه
بارواح الرعايه الغربيين للخروج من
السودان
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه يجب التركيز على وجه الخصوص على
الاجانب سواء في الخرطوم او السودان في
هكذا وضع هناك حرب وكل حياه كل روح مهمه
بغض النظر من اين تاتي الالتزامات
الانسانيه لا تاخذ في الاعتبار الفئه
المختلفه لمن هم موجودون في السودان لا
اريد ان اركز في حديثي عن الولايات
المتحده وتقوم به دول اوروبيه بالنسبه الى
هذا الوضع الانساني هذا يعود لسياستها
الخارجيه ولكن حنا يكون هناك ازمه انسانيه
نركز على الجميع ممن هم من الفئات على هشه
المعرضه حتى لو كانوا من الاجانب او من
السودانيين
اما بالنسبه الى لعبه الملامه وتقاذف
الاتهامات بين قوى دعم السريع والقوات
المسلحه
كل طرف يفعل الامر نفسه مثل طرف الاخر
هناك بروباجاندا وتضليل دعونا لا ننسى ان
الطرفين
جماعات
بينهما للاطاحه بالبشير عمل سويه
ولا سبب تسبب انقسام التركيز هو الاستمرار
في توجه الى الطرفين والعمل على حل اكثر
استدامه ووقف لاطلاق النار اكثر استدامه
للعوده في النهايه الى طاوله المفاوضات لا
احد منهما يمكنه ان يسير لوحده في عمليه
العمليه السياسيه حتى الان لم يقتنع لم
يقتنع اي طرف منهما
بما تقول ربما
الى ما بعد
فتره من الزمن تكون الحرب قد استعرت اكثر
وخسائرها قد
اتسعت وكبرت اكثر ربما يحصل هذا التواصل
وهنا ساسال السيد الهندي
الا يفكر الطرفان
بالنتائج السلبيه على السودانيين بالمقاسي
الانسانيه بالقتله والجرحى الذين يسقطون
يعني هل يمكن
لهؤلاء المتحاربين ان ينظروا ولو لبرهه
الى السودانيين
ومئاسيهم واوضاعهم في هذه المرحله
طبعا للحرب اثار الانسانيه كبيره جدا
مدمره والان كثير من المدن تاثرت في هذه
الحرب خلال اسبوعين فقط مدينه بحري ولكن
يجب ان يحمل للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
التي تمتلك اسلحه فتاكه التي تغاتل بطيران
الميت 29 وطيران حديث جدا ان الاصابات
محدده ومباشره في معسكرات الدعم السريع لو
ان الجيش السوداني جيش غير حرفي طياريه
غير حرفيين لكان هنالك دمار كامل للخرطوم
في خلال يومين وكان كانت الجثث بالالاف في
الشوارع ولكن العمليه الدقيقه جدا اصابه
الطيران للمعسكرات 11 معسكر في ولايه
الخرطوم تم تدميرها بالكامل قوات الدعم
السريع منتشره كماركبات في مناطق مختلفه
في العاصمه ولكن ليس لديها مقر الان ليس
هنالك رئاسه اسمها رئاسه قوات الدعم
السريع لانه في اليوم الاول
تدمير مبنى رئاسه الدعم السريع الان
يتحركون على طريق الثروه الفرع على طريقه
حرب العصابات وكذا هناك نقطه مهمه قالها
الضيفه من ابويا ان الجيش هو الذي
الجيش هو الذي اعتقل البشير البرهان شخصيا
هو الذي اعتقل البشير فكيف تقول انه فلول
يعني
وهذا كلام غير جيش السودان الجيش قومي
حرب السيطره
السيد حافظ يعني يقول السيد الهندي لكل
حرب اثار وكان الامر يجب ان يسلم به طيب
حرب السيطره بين الجنرلين بين البرهان
وحميدتي هل تستحق كل هذا الثمن
هل يعقل ان يدفع السودانيون كل هذا الثمن
من اجل السيطره
والخلاف بين الدعم السريع والجيش
وذكرت مرارا ان الحرب هذه ليس لديها اي
مبررات يا اخلاقيه وانها منزوعه الشرعيه
وبالتالي لا تستحق بالطبع لا يستحق
المواطن ولا السودان ان يدفع كل هذا الثمن
مقابل المبررات التي ذكرت اثناء الحرب
وبالتالي هذا يقودنا مباشره الى غياب
الاراده لدى يعني اطراف مختلفه تدفع
بالقوات المسلحه للذهاب نحو الحرب وحل
المشكله الكبيره التي يعانيها السودان
بالطريقه الخشنه هناك نقاش يجري
بعد الصداقه حول عمليه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري هذا هو
المسار ان المسار الحرب مسار الحرب يحقق
له مكاتب يلغي وجود الدعم السريع وكذلك
يلغي العمليه السياسيه التي كانت تجري
وكانت يعني تخطط لتشكيل مؤسسات متفق عليها
هذا هو الذي يعني اشعل الحرب لكن بصوره
عامه نستطيع ان نقول ان المسار الذي كانت
تمضي فيه الامور ينبغي العوده الان وليس
في اخر وبالتالي اتفق على ذلك مثل هناك
مشكله ونرجو ان يتم ذلك قريبا في
المفاوضات التي اتفق عليها في جده قريبا
في في في شكرا لك حافظ كبير الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي من الخرطوم شكرا للهند عز
الدين من الخرطوم ايضا الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي واشكر ديفيد اوتو اندلي من ابوجا
مدير مركز جنيف للامن والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]